behind you a colossal hurricane moments
away from making landfall
in front of you
a towering tornado
fast tracking its way toward the
opposing storm
and you
times run out escape
is
futile
would these two storms merge into a new
kind of catastrophe
how much would it be capable of
destroying
and can you survive this clash of wind
titans
this is what if and here's what would
happen if a tornado hit a hurricane
hurricanes are formed when a weather
disturbance such as a thunderstorm moves
across an ocean warmer than 26.5 degrees
the storm pulls in hot and humid air
from the warm waters and condensation
continuously feeds the hurricane with
more and more clouds
cooler air rushes in to fill up the low
air pressure zone left by all that hot
air being forced upward creating
ferocious winds in the process
a category 5 hurricane the biggest among
them has a wind speed of 200 252
kilometers per hour
and it brings with it the potential for
catastrophic damage backed by storm
surges as high as 8 meters
and then you have a tornado
these are rotating columns of wind
extending from the ground all the way up
to a thunderstorm
every one of them requires a supercell
to form also known as a giant storm
tornadoes can stretch as wide as 460
meters and although they tend to last
less than 10 minutes on average
their destructive winds can be well over
320 kilometers per hour
so
what would it look like if these two
literal airbenders collided
a big part of this showdown would come
down to which of these two is more
powerful in terms of pure might a
tornado's winds can be stronger than
hurricanes and yet hurricanes unlike
tornadoes last for days instead of just
minutes
they're also much larger and tend to
cause a lot more damage
it's also not uncommon for tornadoes to
form from hurricanes and their giant
thunderstorms
if you were trapped in a really big
tempest you could even witness what
seems like a whole group of tornadoes
colliding with each other
merging and breaking apart
that's what scientists call a
multi-vortex tornado
it's a single tornado that has formed
anywhere from two to five funnel clouds
rotating around each other
on the other hand hurricanes could
technically come in contact with each
other
if two of them end up less than 1500
kilometers apart they may start to
rotate around each other in what's known
as the fujiwara effect or more fittingly
the fujiwara dance
now if two hurricanes come within 300
kilometers of each other the stronger
one can absorb the smaller one
this is what happened in 1995 when
hurricane iris and tropical storm karen
came in close contact
the two rotated i mean danced around
each other before the tougher iris
swallowed poor karen
but let's get to the encounter we're all
here for
a tornado and a hurricane meeting
head-to-head
what would it feel like to witness their
clash
well as the hurricane was approaching
you you'd see a rainstorm it would be
accompanied by strong winds and the
eerie sound of early warning sirens
the gusts of wind would build up until
they roared only yelling would allow you
to communicate with others
sooner rather than later you'd have a
hard time remaining on your feet
trees would bend break and even be
ripped straight out of the ground
roofs would be torn off in your
neighborhood and fly away like paper
airplanes
along with that car you've yet to pay
off
oh bye bye
i mean not that you'd be able to witness
it the rain would be coming down so hard
it would be nearly impossible to see
anything at all
and then you'd see it
the massive tornado
as they got closer the two storms would
start to orbit around each other in an
epic fujiwara dance-off
this swirling whirlwind of an encounter
between destructive foes would then end
with two possible outcomes
the tornado and the hurricane splitting
apart from their dance and going their
own way or the sheer size of the
hurricane absorbing the tornado vortex
which i'm sorry to say wouldn't be too
exciting
the tornado's funnel would just dry up
and go back into the clouds
in this case the hurricane would emerge
the winner
but despite the power of its former
dance partner the hurricane's victory
wouldn't even make it any stronger
remember hurricanes can only feed
themselves from warm ocean water
not from other storms like tornadoes
not that it means you're out of danger
you'd still better hurry and take
shelter otherwise you'd go flying
through the air alongside all those
newly destroyed rooftops
and although we didn't end up witnessing
a tornado the sight of either of these
natural disasters should tell you it's
time to run for cover
but if you're still craving fireworks in
mayhem
how about dumping an active volcano into
the path of your tornado
i hope you're in the mood for a spinning
vortex from hell
because
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]
you